hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and ah
i'm just checking in on you that's all
this is i'm just checking in to see how
it's going it's opening back up baby
friend of mine in new york city
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened i was
watching this philly uh
washington game it was five to five guy
hits a [ __ ] home run
two run shot dude
all of a sudden it's nine to five i
don't know what happened what's funny
was the [ __ ] second baseman
i was enjoying on the uh when washington
senators was uh making fun of the philly
crowd that was giving him [ __ ] so of
course you know i'm rooting for him
um any any performer that's given a
crowd [ __ ]
i love an athlete on the road trashing
the home base fans it's one of my
favorite things to watch
unless it's fans of a boston team then
then i take it personally
you know so i'm kind of like you know
the people that [ __ ]
at a comedy show now where everything's
a joke until it comes around to their
neighborhood then it's not funny
right what am i talking about here i
can't remember what the i just i had a
thought i left oh so a friend of mine
was in new york city
saw the foo fighters
at madison square garden it was sold out
with 20 000 people there how great is
that
it's bad we're back okay despite the
fact we had the orange-headed [ __ ]
and now we got forgetful freddie thank
god for doctors and scientists and all
and everybody who worked their asses off
um getting us out of this thing i can't
wait oh freckles
freckles is going back to vegas
turn into this scene i don't know what
crime whatever the [ __ ] it is
all those bodies are buried out there in
that [ __ ] lake not buried
[ __ ] anchored down can you imagine
when globe like [ __ ] global warming
when lake mead dries up how many [ __ ]
skeletons
i'm gonna be [ __ ] chad to a goddamn
dryer or something at the bottom of that
lake however the [ __ ] they
weighed them down um
anyway i'm very excited to get back out
on the road and i'm gonna be doing some
uh
extended shows extended time
down at the comedy store next week and
uh making sure my hour is where it needs
to be
and these are my first indoor shows on
the road regular shows since this whole
thing started
so happy to be back and uh
it's my first like road gig since um
that that run of shows i did in december
so
it's we get it bill it's been a while
okay all right
sorry so anyway
um that's where the hell i'm at so let's
talk some sports here as i'm watching a
ball game in the middle of the [ __ ]
day
you know so great to have a friggin
afternoon game on
sitting here you know my little [ __ ]
area out here in the garage
i got myself an ice cold [ __ ] root
beer a
w they want a sponsor kidding
they don't need me they got their own
[ __ ] stands out there
that's one of my i cannot not stop at
one of those when i'm on the road when
there's an a w
[ __ ] sandwich place there's like
three of them left
i'm like i gotta go in there and eat
some heart attack food there
um anyway let's talk sports here
um jesus christ the montreal canadiens
i hate to tell you how much i'm enjoying
just watching them as a team they're
[ __ ] great
i mean they just shot the [ __ ]
knights down last night
they just shut it down they played the
whole [ __ ] game in their own end
the vegas knights did
their power play isn't worth a [ __ ] now
i mean i know it's a little back and
forth i was hoping with vegas won the
previous game that it was gonna like
turn the tide and all right
what are we doing here but um
they have literally just shut down their
top two lines so now i'm already
thinking like okay wait a minute
if they play tampa
in the final can they like uh
and they shut down their top two [ __ ]
lines
not saying that you know vegas compares
to them
um i mean they have a legit
[ __ ] shot they're still saying that
on the nhl network the surprising
montreal canadiens well after that game
last night
it's no longer surprising they're a
great [ __ ] team
they really are so um who knows maybe an
original six team will win it and this
will be the first time the cup has been
in canada
i know i'm getting a little ahead of
myself here since 1993.
all right there's people uh
[ __ ] 28 years old walking around
27 28 years old in canada
you know drinking a mulch and sitting at
a bar talking to some old timer who's
like you know
34 old enough to remember it so tell me
this once again when you were a kid
the stanley cup was in canada i'm
telling you
the canadians want it and like it was
here for a year
it was here for a year that's i believe
i didn't think it was legal at this
point yeah somebody from canada has got
to win it
you know god knows it's not gonna be
toronto you [ __ ] [ __ ]
up three games to ones against those
french [ __ ] [ __ ]
just blow it and then you blow it again
and then you blow it again hey let's get
the puck up on our own [ __ ] end see
how that works
jesus christ that bugged me but what do
you expect
it's time it's time to take the gloves
off with the toronto [ __ ] maple leafs
you just got to give them [ __ ] i know
canada is supposed to be
you know allegedly nice i think if
you're white it's a really nice place to
live
but even then you feel the prejudices
all right i know
that all the [ __ ] people in toronto
and montreal
okay you respect vancouver
you respect it okay you give it an atta
boy
not bad for a city out there but there's
no there's no
no [ __ ] world
do you [ __ ] respect calgary
admit it you you know you think they're
a bunch of animals
huh cattle farmers and [ __ ] oil men
right that's your texas
okay in toronto and montreal is like new
york and la where they think everything
else is a [ __ ] flyover place and then
vancouver's like your san francisco
but calgary oh
calgary is [ __ ] lubbock texas
i want to do all the cities here
all right winnipeg is des moines iowa
edmonton
edmonton's is i would say is like
is like montana or wyoming
well you don't respect the people but
you'd really want to [ __ ] own a
vacation property there you know just to
get away from the city
um i'm just guessing here and for those
of you listening this podcast
from montana or wyoming um
if you were offended i want you to know
that i meant it we don't respect you
okay but we would love to own a log
cabin
and have somebody else chop the wood for
us as we go out there and pretend that
we know how to tie whatever [ __ ]
thing you use to tie something to hold
something down
all right we don't respect you and i'll
tell you this if you got a problem with
it
okay you get your [ __ ] car
you come out here to hollywood and you
[ __ ] bring it
no kidding stand down
some guy reaching for his [ __ ] rifle
right now tell you what boy i'll get on
top of that hollywood sign i'll pick you
all off because you're sitting there
eating an impossible burger
out there in holly weird one of the
worst
insults ever holly weird oh
bird
this is the latest not a holly weird
that's as bad as when you know remember
gaddafi
in the papers over here would call them
wacky gaddafi like they literally
couldn't even come up with a [ __ ]
nick they couldn't come up with
something that
rhymed with gaddafi
so they had they had to change the
pronunciation of his last
wacky cadets this guy wacky
you know what's funny that's all it
takes is if it [ __ ] rhymes
or it's insulting and sort of sounds
like what it was you can get half the
people on your side
you know all those people that say holly
weird they think we're out here [ __ ]
uh drinking baby blood
um you know i'm not saying it doesn't go
down
okay i haven't reached that level the
business okay
[Music]
i think that's what they do to pay you
they give you a star in the
when you figure out what's going on out
here that's when they give you a star
on the hollywood walk of fame to to get
that's their hush money
all right listen you got us we're
drinking baby blood out here okay i mean
what did you think was going on you know
all this money out here
eventually we were going to get boarded
[ __ ] putting ketchup on the burger
right
um and this is how that's how they they
silence them they give you a three
picture deal and then you get a star in
the hollywood walk of fame that's
what i'm saying i'm going with that
all right that's my first hot take of
the podcast
deal with it man dude what happened to
the [ __ ] islanders
you know what happened to the islanders
is i said i thought they were a good
team that's what happens
when i when i say that that team is a
good team then you know
i've lost my touch man i got two kids i
don't i don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] about
anything anymore so
not like you guys didn't always think
that but you know
um i am sitting in a letter chair by the
way so all this shifting and [ __ ] if
you're [ __ ] once again gonna think
that i have some sort of flatulence
problem not saying i do
or i don't okay i might but it's the
[ __ ] chair okay
um
so anyway last night i went out
and uh i had dinner with the buddy of
mine that was in town and brought my
lovely wife
and um my wife got pissed at me because
the other night we were at a
little get-together but a lot of
get-togethers this month
um and uh
some of these women they were talking
about sex in the city and how they still
watch and everything i go how do you
guys watch that show
i don't know i like it it takes me back
to this time of my life and i go okay i
get that because i watch these movies in
the 70s
it takes me back to a certain time in
life i get it i go but you can't tell me
that you think it's funny
right and my wife just shoots me this
[ __ ] look and i'm like oh
there goes the car ride home right
[Music]
she gives me the look right so anyway
you know so i heard it about on that one
why can't you just let people like what
they like
it's not my job sweetheart um so i
[ __ ]
uh last night we're out to dinner
and my wife's talking to my buddy and
they bring up sex in the city and the
guy actually goes you know what i like
it if i'm with
some woman or whatever and she's into it
i can watch it or whatever
i go you can deal with those jokes and
he goes well you know he goes there's so
bad it's kind of like it's funny right
so i'm like all right so then i just
started doing
the one who bangs every guys just
started doing this stupid
like over-the-top character you know
with those dumb puns
you know throughout the dinner what you
know
if somebody said like oh you know what i
want to go out and uh
you know tomorrow i want to get some
donuts and i'd be like oh
i never go into a donut shop i just want
i can't deal with it unless i'm the only
hole in the room and then i go like you
know those bad sex and city jokes and i
just go
sex in the city honey try to keep up
i just kept doing that the whole [ __ ]
meal was annoying the [ __ ] out of my
wife and then eventually she found it
funny and then she started doing it
so that became like the running joke sex
in the city honey
try and keep up right whatever the you
know
you know can i bring the check over
that's not all you can bring over you
know whatever the [ __ ] it is right
so um
what was i gonna say uh whatever we did
that for the rest of the meal so today
i'm in the [ __ ]
um i'm in in the uh
this uber because i had to pick up my
car right
and i'm in the uber and my buddies from
last night sends me a [ __ ] voice text
with one of those jokes and the voice
text goes into my headphones it was one
of those stupid jokes
and then he sent the next voice text
which was sext in the city honey
try and keep up right except when i hit
play for some reason it played out loud
in the uber
so we're just riding quietly in the car
and son just goes
sex in the city honey and i quickly hit
stop
there was just nothing right
and i'm looking at the driver going
there's no way he's not going to look at
me
and it took him like [ __ ] a quarter
of a mile half
mile and then finally he does that quick
he didn't move his head he just did the
quick eyeball look into the rearview
mirror to look at me like what the [ __ ]
is what have i
picked up in my car um
embarrassing embarrassing moment for me
um
i don't have any of the reads yet i'm
just [ __ ]
sitting here reading all this [ __ ]
bambi everybody
bam b you know when running a business
hr issues can kill you wrongful
termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulation somebody hitting their head
on the bubbler
and hr managers salaries hey those
aren't cheap either an average of 70
000 a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
businesses
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy
and maintain your compliance all for
just
99 dollars a month
with bama you can change you can change
hr from your biggest liability
to your biggest strength your dedicated
hr manager is available by phone email
or or real-time chat from onboard
boarding terminations they customize
your policies to fit
your businesses from onboarding to
terminations oh from bringing people on
to kicking them out the door
they customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day all for just 99
a month month-to-month no hidden fees
cancel any time
you didn't start your business because
you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance
let bambi help uh get your free hr audit
today
free go to bambi.com b-u-r-r right now
to schedule your free
hr audit that's bambi.com
b-a-m-b-e-e-dot-com
for only 99 a month all right liquid
death everybody i love these guys
i love these guys a company doing the
right thing thinking about the
environment while they make money it's
not hard people
uh liquid death there's a there's a new
brand out there that looks like
tall boys of beer but guess what it's
not
no way no beer in this bad boy just
fresh
mountain spring water from the alps
perfect for you want to stay hydrated
and look cool and save the environment
time for a drinking game
hey pass me that liquid death let's go
you can still drive
give that ice cold aluminum can with the
skull oh give me that
ice cold aluminum can with the skull
we're getting crazy tonight
the water is giving me life why do they
call it liquid death
because liquid death will brutally
murder your thirst people come on i'm
doing water jokes here people
and these aluminum tall boys are
indefinitely recyclable
uh infinitely sorry recyclables so they
bringing death to plastic bottles that's
why i love this [ __ ]
uh that's right death to plastic liquid
death also donates 10
of their profits to help kill plastic
pollution forever
try to think of something more hardcore
than that spoiler
you can't murder your thirst and kill
plastic pollution save the earth with
liquid death it takes up to a thousand
years for a plastic bottle to decompose
your plastic will outlive you in a
million other generations it seems
aluminum is
infinitely recyclable when jesus finally
comes back
he's going to be wading through plastic
bottles if we don't stop
aluminum is an infinitely recyclable and
actually profitable for recycling
facilities looks cool okay we've done
all this stuff
you'll see these cans popping up
everywhere liquid death is available at
your
at your local whole foods or 7-eleven
but you can get a special deal through
me go to liquiddeth.com to get a free
set of koozies for your first order of
any case of water
and while you're waiting your free
koozies uh for
you waiting for your free koozies to
arrive grab some liquid death at whole
foods
or 7-eleven that's liquiddeth.comburr
to get a free set of koozies with your
first order of any case of water
grab some cans now and completely murder
your
thirst but i have all this [ __ ] work
i have to do
never ends right never ends does it
i'm calling this right now when
everybody goes back to work and has to
be back in the office and all of that
type of [ __ ] they're gonna have like you
know hey you know
that pandemic wasn't that bad i don't
think i uh i don't think i missed going
into the [ __ ]
um so anyway uh i got my car back it's
all fixed
cost me a [ __ ] fortune um
but hey let's talk a little hoop here i
can't remember if i
said this yet i was 100 wrong you know
about the [ __ ]
pylon teams both of them lost this year
so i guess they still suck i hate the
[ __ ] pile on teams
but it was fun to root against them um
and how about those phoenix suns
last night with the last second
alley-oop
to go up two games to none against the
la clippers
how about the fact during the game suns
fans
were chanting the iconic beat la
that was that was that celtics fans came
up with
and they were chatting about the lakers
it was sons fans chanting it at the
clippers
in the playoffs huh are we in upside
down world
it is pretty amazing huh so
um jesus christ what a [ __ ] way to
lose a game
it was like .8 seconds left
they throw a [ __ ] alley-oop the guy
catches it
slams it home like he's on a nerf hoop
even he was looking around like really
did we just do that
two games to none all right i'm going
big on this one too because i got
nothing else
when you don't have guests you have to
go big
all right that series
is [ __ ] over
that series is over you're not coming
back
i don't know maybe they will that should
be my sports show i make a big [ __ ]
statement and then i just counter-dicked
it
there is no [ __ ] way they're gonna
lose that series
you know but you know anything's
possible all right we'll be back um
the [ __ ] happened in long island or was
the game in tampa
i had to shut it off when it was three
to nothing said some stupid
oh whatever the [ __ ] i was doing i had
some dumb ass [ __ ] i had to go do
and i was thinking like all right you
know maybe the islanders can make this
three to two but there's no way that
they're gonna come back and win this
game
for some reason i thought it was three
to nothing and it was like the third
period my eyes are starting to go here
but it was still the first period
they [ __ ] they lost eight to nothing
touchdown with the two-point conversion
as joe bartnick of the puck off podcast
says
um but the great thing is is that only
costs you know it only counts as one
victory
that that series is over okay here's my
predictions
all right montreal is one in the series
all right
i don't know if you listen my last
podcast i said i said that [ __ ]
i said that tam i said that uh vegas was
gonna win
and then i i was looking at the
islanders that were they were gonna beat
tampa and now i'm flipping
i'm flip-flopping i think it's gonna be
a tampa
montreal final
and uh the whole time i've been picking
against montreal
i am now converted i think they shut
down the first two the top two lines of
tampa
and uh they hoist the cup for the first
time in 28 years
and bring the first the cup first cup
back to canada in 28 years
and they'll bring that cup all around
the country
except when they have road games against
calgary and edmonton
because they don't trust the animals in
that province
what do you think about that are you
from canada you can tell me anything
differently
you're gonna tell me okay if you're some
lady living up there in canada
you go away to college and you come home
and you say to your dad this is my
boyfriend and he finds out he's from
calgary
what's the first thing he's doing he's
looking down at his shoes
to see if it's got oil or cow [ __ ] on it
that's what he's doing that's how it is
up there i don't give a [ __ ] what
michael moore said in his little
documentary up there where he made it
look all
cutesy and everybody was getting along
you know hockey is a barbaric
[ __ ] sport skating around with clubs
and it's okay to beat the [ __ ] out of
each other
during the game and you can do it three
times until you get kicked out
all right this is what happened in that
little happy-go-lucky they came up with
that look at us down here
you know is it because we got all of our
[ __ ] violence out on
uh you know native americans
slavery all of that we've done enough
evil [ __ ] we needed to cover our tracks
so we came up with baseball
and maybe up in canada they'd been so
[ __ ] nice
they were just so sick of being pleasant
what was that jim carrey movie good
morning good evening and good night
whatever he would say there
they got so sick of being like that
that when they get out on the ice and
they got a club in their hand they just
all they're just thinking about is how
much they hate their [ __ ] neighbor
and then this sport comes about
well maybe i'm a [ __ ] is that joe
girardi coach in the [ __ ] phillies i
didn't know that
he still looks like he could [ __ ]
throw you through a wall doesn't he
how could that guy be anything other
than a catcher
um i mean her coach he's a manager but
you know what i mean
that guy you just look at him like that
i bet when he was eight years old you're
like that guy is gonna play professional
baseball he's gonna be a catcher you
just knew it
um i don't know
maybe i'm superimposing my own [ __ ]
problems
on uh on your country i'll leave it at
that
i'm looking at a commercial right now
and i swear to god the person in it
looks like tina yells from uh
from [ __ ] uh facts to life fast
harper relief tom's natural um all right
who's getting new people i ran out of
[ __ ] to say [ __ ] 30 seconds into this
podcast but you're still here listening
aren't you
what does that say about you you like
how i did that
you tuned in to be entertained i'm not
doing it and then i'm gonna make it your
fault
like this whole thing was an experiment
for me to find out
how [ __ ] boring your life is i'll
tell you what won't be boring is i did
the conan o'brien podcast
conan needs a friend taped it on friday
and
i think it's coming out this week and
uh it's was one of the hardest i've ever
laughed on a podcast
we kind of just got into a zone
and acted like idiots i don't even want
to i tried to come home and tell my wife
what we were riffing about at the end of
it i don't want to ruin it
and she was just staring at me
i texted kona good i tried to explain it
to my wife
and he was like no no that's one of
those ones you can't you can't recreate
that you got to be there for that so uh
look for that um look for that episode
oh and also i finished watching that
amazing movie investigation of a citizen
above suspicion
now if you're only kind of in the movies
you're not going to enjoy it because the
english that they dubbed over these
italian actors who
looked like they were actually speaking
english is so [ __ ] bad
it might bother you but um
it's a really really amazing movie the
way the whole thing is shot and
everything
and uh i'll tell you the next one that
i'm gonna be watching here
if you guys want to keep up and then
hear
uh my [ __ ] um
my [ __ ] take on it here let's see
who the hell sent it to me
there we go all right the next movie i'm
going to be watching is
the missouri breaks
has marlon brando
uh and jack nicholson
and his here's the log line how they
sell the movie one
steals one kills one dies
one steals one kills one dies i mean
that's [ __ ] great it's weird that
there's only two guys there the math
doesn't work out for me
harry dean stanton one of my favorites
ever is in this movie
um i'm gonna be watching that [ __ ]
that's kind of what i've been into
lately i don't know why just watching
these weird not weird
good movies that i [ __ ] missed when i
was growing up um
so anyway i'm gonna be doing some it's
weird i'm doing these shows at the
comedy store to get ready for the shows
that i'm gonna be doing in vegas
and then now i'm doing shows to get
ready for the shows that's
over the shows to get ready for vegas
it never ends never ends that's that's
what you got to do
you know i was talking to my wife my
lovely wife the other day
and i was talking to her because she's
got this great idea for a show
then we kind of been working on it and i
was telling her
that all you got to do is just complete
this thing right like that's the big
thing
with uh the difference between something
happening and not happening is you
completing it not this person not that
person not the people over there
it's you because there's a lot of [ __ ]
out there right now everybody's like oh
my god
i did what it happened if it wasn't for
this
gatekeeper
and it's just like i was okay all right
so this person's a [ __ ]
but there's a million people out there
find somebody else make it yourself
if you like this person kills it if you
allow them to
if you're going to give them that much
power you know so
if you're out there right now and you
got something that you want to do just
[ __ ] complete it
if you complete it
you know it's gonna happen as simple as
that i know that's stupid but it is
and um i used to be one of those people
i would not complete [ __ ] i would
oh could i start [ __ ] nobody nobody was
better at
starting things and not completing them
you know
starting a book starting a script
starting this starting working out
starting [ __ ] whatever
and just not finishing it i still have
problems with that but what i i started
to do
is i realized that
not finishing things had seeped was
was part of my whole life
you know i'd come home from trips i
wouldn't unpack my luggage would be
sitting there for like a [ __ ] week
and then the next day more [ __ ] that i
needed to you know handle i didn't
handle and next thing you know my
apartment would be a mess
and when i started to understand is that
every day there's going to be [ __ ] you
don't want to do
so you should knock it out so then you
know the next day you don't have to deal
with that day's problems than the day
before and also
by doing that it taught me to complete
[ __ ]
like when you come back from a trip you
haven't come back yet until you've
unpacked and done all of that [ __ ]
you know and then the next morning you
wake up you know and everything's fine
you finish the dishes from the night
before you finish them you dry them you
put away you come downstairs
clean [ __ ] slate it puts you in a
better mood
and it also it becomes a discipline
that part of eating is is washing the
dishes
drying them and putting them away and
then you start to become this person
that starts [ __ ] and then they finish it
you got an infection they give you the
antibiotics what happens people don't
finish them
and then these [ __ ] [ __ ] germs
they get stronger
the doctor says take all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] till it's gone
it's what you do but that's not what
people do
they don't listen they don't [ __ ]
listen so
that's my thing if you're like me and
you procrastinate and you want to get
something done you don't [ __ ] get it
done
just start with easy [ __ ]
you know just [ __ ] like that doing the
dishes the night before
waking up making the bed completing [ __ ]
and then it becomes it gets in your
[ __ ] dna and it will bug you i i
literally you know
my daughter will go over uh her nana's
house or whatever and she'll come back
she brings
back the scooter or the bike second i
see that thing sitting there i take it
and i bring it out to the garage
and i put the [ __ ] thing away i don't
wait
until the next morning now i'm waking up
the bed isn't made the dishes aren't
done the [ __ ] bike and all of a
sudden
my wife goes could you do me a favor and
then i'm just like what
what is it now right i'm flipping out
and she's like where did that come from
oh it came because i didn't do all the
[ __ ] i needed to do
the night before so i don't know if any
of this [ __ ] makes sense but like i'm
telling you
you start doing that [ __ ] becomes who
you are
and then it seeps into whatever the [ __ ]
it is you want to do
and you complete [ __ ] and then as long
as you're not
fixated on results like i can only
equate it to my business like i'm going
to put out a stand-up special and i put
up the standard special and i would
become the biggest comedian there ever
was right
that's a ridiculous expectation
it's like i'm putting this [ __ ] out and
some people are gonna see it
and some people are gonna like it and
then you know what i'm gonna do it again
and i'm gonna do it again and i'm gonna
do it again and then eventually
i'll have enough [ __ ] people where
i'm a draw on the road and then all of
those ones that sort of
underperformed and it didn't get me
where i was wanted to be people will
then go back and watch
and then all of a sudden you have this
body of work that's how it works so
whatev whatever your [ __ ] deal is
whatever your dream is
oh billy inspiration face is that what
i'm doing this week i don't know
it was just something i was thinking
about because the other day i was
talking to somebody and they were like
they were just doing that [ __ ] well if i
do this and what if this
if that happens hey what if that [ __ ]
doesn't happen
what if you don't give a [ __ ] and no
matter what
you just do it what about that
well i don't want to do that that's
scary well then go [ __ ] yourself all
right that's the podcast
everybody enjoy the music picked out by
the greek freak the great andrew
themeless
and uh then we go as paul versus he
calls in the greek freak
and then uh we have a bonus thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast coming in
right after uh right after the music and
it's uh
from i don't know a few years ago
however andrew works it out that's it
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and uh
i'll talk to you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
june 24th 2013 how are you how's it
going i know it's tuesday morning had to
do the math there on the date i
apologize for not
uh doing the podcast earlier
i was i was in new york this weekend
being a fancy man
as jimmy norton would say i was at the
uh the
the premiere of this movie that i have a
really small role in
it's called the heat it stars sandra
bullock
and uh and melissa mccarthy
and uh michael rappaport and all the all
these
all these people all these people are in
it and uh yours truly oh billy redface
is in it for a couple of seconds don't
blink
or you will miss me but that movie comes
out this weekend
um this upcoming weekend i should say so
uh do me a solid dad dude go out and
check it out if you can
i'd really appreciate it's a very funny
movie and uh
i got to do the whole hollywood thing
went back to new york walked the [ __ ]
red carpet
you know and answered a couple two or
three questions i went in i saw the
movie
i enjoyed it and then i got drunk with
joe derosa
and paul versi you know what else could
you ask for in a weekend
i know what you could ask for yeah
[ __ ] game six
victory to send it to [ __ ] game
seven back in chicago
that's something i could have asked for
i could ask for the hockey guards to be
just how about we get a [ __ ] lucky
bounce how about one of our shots goes
off the boards and bounces in a weird
way
and ricochets off five [ __ ] guys and
goes in the net can we get
one of those just one and you know what
it was not meant to be
hats off to the uh stanley cup champions
chicago blackhawks they are definitely
without a doubt the best team
uh this year and um
you know they were just they were just
better it's all i can say they were
better
uh one goal better every [ __ ] game it
seemed
but um i gotta admit i i you know
there's no one on that team i hate and
that says something after watching them
for six games like nobody on their
team's a [ __ ]
you know they got one they they got they
have one pest that's it other than that
you know we got a pest and
uh marshawn so i will tell you what
[ __ ] annoyed me though
is i don't know what this white-haired
dude's name is
but i'm watching on nhl.com how do you
mispronounce
chara's name you know he kept calling
chera
well the broads got uh they got chara
back there eating up bali
it's like he just got brought up from
the [ __ ] miners
you guys want a norris trophy you can't
pronounce his [ __ ] name correctly
um anyways jesus christ you want to talk
about a [ __ ] just taking the wind out
of your sails
sitting there on the edge of your seat
thinking okay just hold on hold on hold
on don't let them tie it up they [ __ ]
tie it up and then they score another
one
what was it 17 seconds later the first
one i'll go with but you just you can't
let that other one happen
but uh i don't know [ __ ] dave bowling
guys just a great hockey player i don't
know how the [ __ ] that happened how does
it happen
you know it kills me [ __ ] kills me
but um
it was a great series and an original 16
one and i actually
still like the blackhawks and i think
they have [ __ ] great uniforms
and uh god damn it
god [ __ ] damn what the [ __ ] two
ghosts
i mean we literally went from okay i
mean i'm like
thinking in my head all right game seven
can do you think they can do it again
and
as i'm freaking out hold on hold on hold
on and then they [ __ ] tie it up
and i was like oh god another [ __ ]
overtime you're killing me
can i [ __ ] mentally make it through
another [ __ ] overtime as i sit here
having no effect on the game for some
reason stressing out
can i make it through it oh right there
i guess i guess we don't have to go to
overtime
thank you dave bolin for just uh [ __ ]
ending that real quick
um
but i got to tell you um i was blown
away by what the bruins were able to do
this season
uh that you know actually you know game
one and game six
was kind of the bruins team that i saw
all years where they would get up
2-1-3-1 and they had problems holding on
to a lead so i actually thought
i didn't even think they were going to
make it out of the first round so i
can't say
i was psyched that that happened
whatever we got a great core base we can
we come back bring up [ __ ] dougie
hamilton he got a lot of experience
the only good thing about the hawks
winning it in boston was i didn't have
to listen to that stupid
just when you think nothing can be more
annoying than
whoa or whatever after the after a goal
that [ __ ] mindless song and looking
at those
fat [ __ ] brat eating chicago fans
with their dumb mustaches do they even
have am i just thinking of a [ __ ] snl
sketch
at that [ __ ] song
you might as well be you might as well s
what is that [ __ ] song i get knocked
down
but i get up good like those are songs
that should only be played
you know when you're on a cruise ship
and you've just signed up for the
aerobics class
you know what i mean nobody listens to
those [ __ ] songs you really got to
get rid of that other than that top to
bottom i think chicago is a great
organization but uh
you know they always got to have
something [ __ ] douchey
to either appeal to kids or just get
mindless fiddle fat elite and [ __ ]
morons to buy tickets
yeah i did say fiddle faddle it still
exists
um god damn it that [ __ ] was good when
you were kid
sending it right through the [ __ ]
roof with the sugar
they always got to have something like
that you know like the red sox
wally really
wally
how many women were in the room when
that came up that [ __ ] name
oh my god that's cute you know what i'm
not going to blame women
this is not a sex uh battle of the
sexist topic this is just a [ __ ]
douche chill topic and you you can file
all of that
let's add to it you know what i mean now
i'm being honest about my teams why
don't we do that next week
for a topic write in something
you know of your home team that they do
that they just really that's just such a
blatant
[ __ ] reach out to try to grab
non-sports fans
um you know what's creepy about wally
with the boston red sox is that's really
like
i mean a team is basically like a
religion so you're trying to get them
when they're young
so it's it's like you're giving them
candy
you know just something creepy about it
we'll have a [ __ ] adult
come walking up in some big furry
[ __ ] outfit or whatever the hell the
goddamn thing wears
right be like on a mission
to be friendly to kids not because it's
the right thing to do
not because you love kids because you
know someday that kid
is going to have some sort of alcohol
problem and want to
hopefully want to get hammered at your
ballpark and you want his booze money in
your [ __ ] pocket
right all done under the guys are
dressing up like a [ __ ] woolly
mammoth
you know oh that's right people i'm
pulling i'm i'm looking behind the
curtain of mask
mascots this week i'm pulling back that
curtain i'm showing you the ugly [ __ ]
truth
um oh it's gonna be a while
it's going to be a while before i get
over the kick and the balls that that
last [ __ ] minute and 10 seconds was
it was i think they kicked my left ball
first and then the
dave bolin was the [ __ ] right ball
not only did they knock the bruins
out of the playoffs not only do we not
win the cup but now
simultaneously hockey is over
and i have to wait for the nhl
all the way until october so
you know what you know i'm gonna get
over this bruins loss
i'm gonna watch the day game there's
nothing better than watching a day game
uh dodgers game out here you just sit
there by yourself
sipping on a [ __ ] lager and you
listen to vince scully it's great
it takes a second though like i think
how deep into the uh
the summer obviously there was a strike
this year but how deep into
into the summer that basketball and the
nhl goes and like how up tempo and high
scoring and all that well
hockey's not really high scoring but
whatever um
just how the energy level to go from
that
to then settle into a great day for a
ball game uh we got a couple of
gonna be a pitchers duel here at
kamitsky
that's ball one yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah didn't even play that as
fast
just [ __ ] you got to settle into it
you have to settle into baseball you
know what i mean it's like you ever been
driving like a [ __ ] maniac
and then your girl looks at you and just
like you're scaring me
stop it right and then you have to
[ __ ] mentally
bring yourself down from that playoff
energy that you were [ __ ]
driving with and you got to somehow calm
yourself down
and then literally wave somebody into
your lane
that's what it's like to go from the
stanley cup finals
or even the nba finals the nba finals
were great that was another heartbreaker
watching the spurs lose that one
and um and my frustration continues with
these pile on [ __ ] teams
i've come to the ex the acceptance that
it is a new [ __ ] error i guess so i'm
gonna quit whining about it
and obviously all of those guys
who won on miami could have won in any
era but it's just
i hate it because i don't know how to
compare them to bird magic and all those
other guys because uh
you know because bird magic and moses
malone never hung out on p diddy's yacht
right with their own line of flip-flops
or whatever the [ __ ] they would have had
back then if it was like today and uh
decided that they were all gonna go join
the [ __ ] milwaukee bucks or something
so i don't know so congratulations also
to the miami heat i don't hate the heat
the way uh
most celtics fans do um or hate
ray allen i mean ray allen wasn't ours
the way miami got him is the same way we
got him so i don't know what you're
crying about
and as far as the miami heat go they
ain't good on them i mean
they're they're always gonna be a
[ __ ] expansion franchise to me
all right with their little single
digits [ __ ] championships
well they got three they got three
is that what they got how many they got
i don't [ __ ] know yeah they got three
and uh they might be the next lakers
because they
bought all three of them
all right enough of my [ __ ] [ __ ]
moaning and complaining and whining
um oh by the way i did last night i
don't know if he's posted it yet
which would be classic jaymore to post
it and then give me [ __ ] for not
retweeting about it
um i did j morris podcast we had a great
time
and uh about 10 15 minutes in i tried to
take him to task
about his flippant [ __ ] or how i read
as a flippant text message
and he [ __ ] took my he took my legs
out by immediately apologizing
it just kind of ended the whole [ __ ]
thing but i don't you know
it was still we still had a great time
um
so anyways what a what a [ __ ] week
in the world of sports especially in
boston the bruins lose a hard break yeah
um dark rivers signs with the [ __ ]
clippers
um i'm i'm gonna believe in danny ainge
on this one
and i'm gonna go with the philosophy
that you don't want to pay a coach seven
million dollars a year
when he has no chance to win because
you're gonna just start from scratch
but i got to tell you like eventually
you're going to need a doc rivers
to take you to the promised land you
know the guy knows how to [ __ ] win
um i don't know it sounded like i know
from
the couple things that i saw it sounded
like doc didn't want to go through a
rebuilding thing and the celtics wanted
to rebuild so they
let him out of his contract so thanks to
dark rivers and everything he did for
bringing the [ __ ] celtics back
and uh i'm gonna believe in danny ainge
as we go through the rebuilding process
although i hate getting rid of [ __ ]
proven people for
draft picks i was actually watching this
morning i couldn't sleep
i was so [ __ ] upset about that loss
last night
and uh i put on the nba channel and i
was watching the 2001
draft and you know it's not the guys
that make it it's the guys that don't
that [ __ ] it just
i forget who the 76ers picked in 2001
but he was some 20 year old kid
you know supposed to be this shot
blocking phenom and i
i never even heard of the guy not like
i'm the biggest
nba fan but uh so that's what makes me
nervous about that [ __ ] so uh
other than that what else happened in
boston sports
aaron hernandez that story gets
sadder and creepier by the [ __ ] day
did you see the guy's house
this [ __ ] house that's it you made it
you had that house at 20 [ __ ] three
i would just think he's just sitting in
that house just wishing he could just
rewind his life [ __ ] six days
you know and just stay home and watch
[ __ ] beethoven part three
you have to be thinking that unless
you're just a complete psycho but uh
all this [ __ ] is a legend at this point
but
all of his [ __ ] actions he's got to
be neck deep in this [ __ ]
can you turn in your cell phone and it
comes in like you drove over it with
your [ __ ] car
you clean your house and then you have a
bunch of people come in and re-clean it
by the way any cops out there any cops
out there
hey you know let's go against the grain
here
um i actually a long time ago when i was
doing the uninformed show
with the uh the teen idol sensation
joe derosa we actually had uh
this police officer come in that we knew
through uh gotham comedy club
and he came in and the big thing was uh
me and joe were gonna tr both of us
individually individually we're gonna
try to come up with the perfect murder
so we come up with our scenarios we
bring the cop in and i go to pitch mine
and this is this is how far i got in
mine i go all right
so me and a friend of mine and then he
goes up that's it he goes you're already
caught
and i'm like what do you mean i'm
already caught he goes the second you
involve
somebody else he goes the chances of
getting caught it's
it's if if mathematically was possible
to go beyond
a hundred percent um
that's what you're doing with that
because now you got
you just have twice the chances of
somebody rolling over somebody getting
paranoid somebody's saying the wrong
[ __ ] thing somebody feeling guilty
somebody leaving some haters at the
crime scene the whole [ __ ] thing
his his basic thing was
if you have no priors and you just go
out and kill somebody that you have no
connection to
no connection to and nobody [ __ ] saw
it
you know how they gonna catch you
and then the other thing he says is do
not move the body
he goes just leave it there
he told me a story about somebody
[ __ ] killed somebody
and felt bad for the dog so he took the
dog with him or something like that and
that's how they ended up connecting him
to the crime scene
was the dog hairs he took the dog and
let it go hoping someone would [ __ ]
rescue it i don't know what but they
found
this the dead dude's dog hairs in his
[ __ ] car it's just
it's over you know what i mean it's
[ __ ] over how did i get on this
subject
it was just a [ __ ] creepy ass week
and then paula dean
running around dropping the [ __ ] n
word evidently is she's making a [ __ ]
souffle
you know i actually met her one time
when i was in atlanta she seemed like a
sweetheart
i told her i go you know what i go you
cook like my mom and she's like you know
what that's like the nicest thing
anybody could say
i don't know what what do you do so now
what so now you fire her
and does that make her less ignorant
does that help her
say the n word less when she's baking
cookies
i don't know but you know what i think
each race should have like an ambassador
right and when somebody does some [ __ ]
like that
like the ambassador just they just go
out and they go fishing for a weekend
you know and they just sort of talk it
out and you give that person
a frame of reference so anytime they
think of some ignorant [ __ ] they go wait
what about so and so i went fishing with
you know it's not all bad
right that guy on espn when he said the
stuff about gay people
you know go send them to a musical
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know but i
don't know if
the firing thing ah jesus christ
oh speaking of jesus no geez
did you guys uh did you guys see that
[ __ ] dude
walk on that wire all the way across the
grand canyon did you see that [ __ ]
that was was one of the most incredible
[ __ ] things i've ever seen in my
life in my life i always have to repeat
that twice when i say in my life
and you know why that is because i saw i
watched wife swap a long time ago this
one family they were living like pirates
if anybody can find this clip for me
it's one of my favorite clips this guy
just decided he
we were all his whole family was going
to live like pirates
they'd dress like pirates and ah again
they just walked around they had no
[ __ ] responsibility
the guy was totally avoiding being like
an adult so he worked from home or
whatever
so they'd swap wives so his pirate wife
leaves and then in comes like some
[ __ ] totally conservative nancy
reagan
business suit wearing woman and she's
just like nah dude you need to go get a
job or whatever so he goes and he does
some job
filing and he comes home that day right
after living like a pirate he has to put
on this monkey suit and go down and
[ __ ]
earn a living and he comes home
and she just goes so how was it and he
goes
that was the worst day
of my life and she goes well you know
and he goes off my
life he screamed it again
it's [ __ ] great so anyways
getting back to the [ __ ] ginger who
walked across the
wire dude i watched it
after because everybody kept tweeting me
going bill hey i'm really rooting for
you
you put on some weight but i'm really
rooting for you to walk across the grand
canyon so
i kind of heard about it so i was
already laughing going all right this
guy must look like me a little bit but
anyways when i was flying back
uh from new york city i watched it
and i i was i was like my palms were
sweating
watching this [ __ ] guy 1500 [ __ ]
feet in the air
with no net no lifeline no anything and
he's walking across the wire
and every step is oh thank you jesus
oh thank you god lord you are
lord thank you for getting rid of the
wind like this [ __ ] 30 mile an hour
wind this guy is and then he's got his
douchebag father going
okay you're uh you're one minute and six
seconds
into the journey you're one minute and
36 seconds he let his dad do this until
about minute 18
and he just finally just goes dad dad i
don't need you to tell me how long i've
been out here
like his [ __ ] arms are tired as hell
um it was like flanders you know getting
mad like he couldn't be like dad but
if i was on the way i'd be like darius
shut the [ __ ] up
all right what difference does it make
how [ __ ] long i'm out here
what am i going to punch a clock and
[ __ ] go to sleep and come back
tomorrow you [ __ ]
trying to walk across the what right
see this [ __ ] guy he's just sitting
not sitting
he's walking across doing like this
little slide step
you know how you would sort of like
insert yourself into a photo to photo
bomb somebody just you know that little
slide step you do
he's doing that with these little ballet
slippers on
now i got to tell you i was interested
that he didn't have those shoes with the
little toes on him
you know those creepy [ __ ] things
that just makes you want to just you
know
it makes your teeth hurt to look at him
i'm surprised he didn't have those maybe
it's his
case he had a problem he could lock his
big toe with the uh the index finger toe
right hang on like a [ __ ] monkey
so anyways he's sitting there stepping
across it going oh thank you lord
thank you jesus jesus all glory to you
oh thank you thank you yahweh
at one point he actually sounded like he
was having sex
he was going yes jesus oh
jesus right
and i know it was bugging people who
aren't religious it didn't bug me at all
i thought that guy was the [ __ ] and if
you think i wouldn't be out there
talking to every god that i had ever
heard of
i would have except i would have been i
would have been cursing
at the same time i would have been oh
thank you god you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus saw i would have been doing that
the whole
[ __ ] way thank you god you
[ __ ] i would be doing that
the whole way at some point i would have
crouched down
let go of that balancing thing and i
just would have been hanging on
to the [ __ ] wire crying but
what would you do dude there's no
[ __ ] way you could ever get me to do
it that guy
is like that guy's the [ __ ] i don't even
know his name
i don't even know if his name if he's
listen listening to this please pray for
me
um dude how is time flying by this fast
23 minutes in 23 minutes in on your
tuesday
um all right let's do let's read a
couple of ads for this week everybody
dude i would have been praying to
everybody oh buddha buddha you fat
[ __ ] just get me across this
i'd want buddha to be laying down in the
cannon in case i felt so i could land on
his [ __ ] stomach
dude that guy had to deal with like i
guess if
if you uh if you're walking in a rhythm
which you know is basically if you have
a consistent
gate to how you're walking when you're
on a wire it starts to bounce up and
down so every once in a while i guess
you either have to slow it down
switch it up or crouch down
like this guy was he took a [ __ ] knee
how you do that on a [ __ ] cable i
don't know
um i'm actually predicting this that
they're going to start setting up
[ __ ] uh
little tight ropes at gyms because it's
good for core strength
you know somebody will somehow analyze
that and they'll put it like literally
two feet off the ground with a bunch of
amf mats all around it
and you got to wear a helmet and a
[ __ ] harness and all this [ __ ] so
nobody gets sued
you know they always do that like
somebody does some really like manly
takes balls the size of the grand canyon
[ __ ]
and then somebody turns it into like a
workout
like the boxing workout they have like
the ufc workout where you do the [ __ ]
rope thing you know
are you shaking out those [ __ ] ropes
doing all the same [ __ ] those guys do
you do everything except
[ __ ] get the balls up to go fight
another man you know
or woman um
so anyways you know i just realized you
know that you ever see that that that
bully beat down thing
which is really uh it's it's a terrible
show
because the cowards
they still don't stand up to him there's
usually two [ __ ] that the dude's
picking on
so it's like why don't you teach them
how to fight they join forces and then
they go in the ring and they fight the
bully
right why are you sitting there having
them outsource their nuts
they're lacking nuts you know what i
mean downloading somebody else's balls
is more
is more uh what they're doing and then
he goes in and he kicks the [ __ ] out of
him to make it a little
fairer you know be great they should
take those those uh the female
ultimate fighters and bring them into
the ring
because they can knock out the average
bully no problem and then what's funny
that's extra humiliating
all right that's just an industry note
for that show all right let's get to the
uh
let's get to the the [ __ ] reads here
uh hulu plus everybody
you've tried streaming hit shows on your
pc on hulu.com
haven't you done that well if you
haven't why don't you catch up with the
rest of us now it's time to start your
free trial of exclusive content
in your living room and on your mobile
devices on hulu plus
with hulu plus you get total control to
watch thousands of shows wherever you
want whenever you want
use hulu plus on connected tvs game
consoles blu-ray
players uh roku apple tv pc
or watch anywhere on your smartphone or
tablet
on demand at all times and with hulu
plus you can
binge on full seasons watch your
favorite current shows
and even full series runs of classic tv
shows it's endless
personally i think this is the new way
that people are going to start watching
tv
you're going to watch it where you want
wherever you want and you're going to
watch entire seasons
um there's just so many this is like a
golden age in television i don't know if
you guys have realized this
but as great as the shows were when i
was coming up in the 70s and 80s and
that type of thing
um they they were nowhere to lev there
was nothing like breaking bad on
television
um nothing like the wire nothing like
all these you know
walking dead walking dead's like a
zombie movie every week
you can watch all of this stuff any way
you want with hulu plus and you can get
caught up
you know so you have to feel out of the
loop if you go to a party and
everybody's talking about some show you
haven't seen
anyways they got all the shows they got
community modern family south park
snl jimmy kimmel family guy and more
hula plus is only 7.99 per month
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hulu plus
that is only available to my podcast
listeners take control your tv
uh watching experience by going to the
podcast page at billboard.com
click on the hulu plus banner for your
extended free trial
trial or go to huluplus.com bill
and start enjoying tv in the buck rogers
age here and uh e-voice
hey what's the reason you're going to
make more money in 2013
e-voice is the reason when your
customers call you'll have your own
toll-free
number a professional greeting dial by
name directory and more
you'll sound like a fortune 500 company
and blow away your competitors
evoice lets you give out one number that
rings wherever you
are the beach the ba doesn't matter
you'll sound like you're at the office
you got to go to evoice.com and use the
promo code bill
evoice even takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly as a text or an email however
you want it done
so you can check your voicemails before
the meeting ends and not look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month right
now my listeners
get a free trial of e-voice for 30 days
stop what you're doing right now hit
pause and
sign up for your e-voice free trial and
see what i'm talking about it's a great
way to support my podcast and an easy
way to make more money this year
go to evoice.com promo code bill that's
eboyz.com promo quote build or just go
to the podcast page on billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner right now
all right back to the podcast everybody
um
oh you know what i've been doing here i
didn't i didn't
mention this to you guys i've been uh
trying to become a little more worldly
i'm trying to i'm trying to learn all
the all the countries and the capitals
oh jesus um i got
i could do the middle east and all of
europe europe's a [ __ ] when you
get to the uh
when you get to eastern europe because
once czechoslovakia and yugoslavia
splintered into like seven or eight
different [ __ ] countries
you know what i mean just [ __ ] you you
never really hear about
like uh what are some of the ones over
there i don't [ __ ] know i don't even
have them in front of me i'm still
trying to memorize them but what i did
learn there was someone i was just like
what the [ __ ] is san marino
san marino capital san marino
and then you had like vad vad dews
lichtenstein
and everybody over here makes fun of
lichtenstein i remember growing up
everybody because it's it's like beepers
and buff
butthead [ __ ] like because the word lick
is in there
what are you doing there [ __ ]
lichtenstein you know stupid [ __ ] like
that
evidently there's like five sovereign
states
in the world uh or cities whatever the
[ __ ] you call them and they kind of
exist as their own little
entities and uh
it sounds if you got the money to live
there they're great the tax rate is low
it's like vatican city liechtenstein
um monaco i think singapore
and then something else that begins with
an m
i don't know if it's malta i don't know
there's just there's five of them
and i got to tell you like i would love
if they have if they ever came up with
this show
called the money trail or blood money or
something i can't
imagine how much is oozing out of those
[ __ ] places vatican city goes without
saying
all right that just goes without [ __ ]
you can't imagine what goes on in that
city right
considering the pope quit even when the
pope's just like listen guys i can't be
the spokesperson for this [ __ ] anymore
um and interestingly enough you never
hear anything about lichtenstein you
never hear anything about [ __ ]
monaco other than the [ __ ] grand prix
and it's just a bunch of rich [ __ ] over
there
tagging [ __ ] top shelf ass
like [ __ ] a third of their goddamn
age
you know how do i get into that party
that's what i want to know
hey by the way did you guys see [ __ ] is
heating up between china and japan
they're going to maybe they're going to
go at it over some islands and you know
would be great
as a citizen of the united states here
you know it'd be phenomenal
if we just stayed the [ __ ] out of it
you know we just stayed the [ __ ] out of
it and you just
just got to watch this renewed rivalry
a rivalry that goes way back to the
beginning of time
all kinds of great [ __ ] games they
had back in the day
you know japan ran up to score
and nan king right the rape and nan king
there's a lot of bad blood
between the two of them this is like
when the celtics and lakers
like rivalry went dormant throughout the
90s
and then it came back with a vengeance
so i think
from what i've it looks like eventually
china and japan
china which is just a [ __ ]
environmental disaster
the biggest mistake they [ __ ] made
they were just like look we're gonna
have so many goddamn people
if you ever decide to attack this
country
there's just gonna be wave after wave
after wave
of [ __ ] human beings coming over the
[ __ ] hill
right did they not know about nuclear
weapons you know you just
where one person can just kind of end
the world i mean why didn't they just go
that route
this part of the podcast is called in
way over his head
[Laughter]
bill bird discussing world events
without really reading up on them
everyone
um so anyways yeah i can do all the
capitals of the middle east
it's great then you hear world news and
you kind of know where [ __ ] is
you know like i didn't know that the
czech republic was tucked right in
between
that like uh poland and germany like
west virginia
between ohio and pennsylvania you see
that i used something normal
something that i could relate to hey
bill why don't you shut the [ __ ] up and
read a question for this week
okay i can do that oh by the way the
email is bill at the mmpodcast.com
if you want to send it um an email let
me know what's the most embarrassing
thing that one of your home
teams does that makes you uh
want to either choke somebody in the
front office or punch the fan next to
you because they're participating i'd
love to hear it
all right butte montana hey
billy boy uh one when you are on your
red state tour
stop and check out butte montana um i'm
excited for your upcoming show in
bozeman montana i happen to live about
an hour west
of bozeman in butte that's just a great
[ __ ] that's the perfect name for a
city in montana
butte montana view where y'all from bu
butte montana i ain't got time for two
syllables
i gotta go mend the fans uh milo is a
southern accent at the [ __ ] most
northern part of the country
actually maine no i'm sorry alaska is
all right you [ __ ] geographical [ __ ]
there uh when you're making the drive
from boise to bozeman you will have to
drive through
montana you uh you're driving through at
a great time to stop for the afternoon
and check it out we have a beaut we have
beautiful old architecture
and old and new giant mines
old and new giant mines you're mining
for giants the [ __ ] does that mean
huge mines i don't know anything about
mine sorry sir
you're talking shop there and he goes
and the day of your show it will be evil
knievel day
i gotta go well the day of the show
might be cutting it a little bit close
we gotta stop in anybody can get a
picture with an elvis impersonator
i've never seen an even evel knievel
impersonator i want to
you know what sir i might i might i
might check that out why am i saying
everything [ __ ] twice get the papers
get the papers
i might i might i might check it out
there there the up uh the uptown i gotta
do it again
now i'm mindfucking myself the uptown is
filled with daredevils stunts
booze good food and crazies something i
thought you guys might like to check out
probably get a good story out of it at
least can't wait for the show apps are
[ __ ] lugly
and um i gotta tell you i love those
kinds of places
i love going to these places that are
considered the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and checking out uh you know the
architecture here in all the [ __ ] uh
history of the places seeing what they
do for fun
i've never heard of an evil knievel day
i'm assuming he's from that area
montana evil knievel the size of balls
he had
he would have [ __ ] he would have
driven his [ __ ] motorcycle
they weighed like 10 000 [ __ ] pounds
in the early 70s he would have driven it
right across that wire
you know with some sort of shoot that
came out too early
knocked that jesus freak right off the
[ __ ] wire
oh thank you jesus oh that step was in
your name
all glory to you god for making these
dancing slippers
marrying too young dearest
billing billingsworth the reddington i
like that one
i would have just gone with
billingsworth reddington
you know what if i ever move to
liechtenstein that's going to be my name
my fake name
when i try to hide my blood money you
know
because one day i go to a show and i
sell the dvds and i take pictures first
and i take the door and i take all the
[ __ ] merch money and then i just
don't do a show
and then i'm gonna relocate to
lichtenstein and i'm gonna go buy
billingsworth reddit billingsworth
readington and i'm gonna have a [ __ ]
pocket watch and uh and a little
spectacle
nice spectacle what do you call that a
little [ __ ] not a gargoyle what do
you call that thing
not a cyclops what do you call that
thing when you gotta you gotta [ __ ] a
bifocal
no by means two not a trifocal a sing a
unit uni focal
i'm going bicycle here hey how many more
wing walkers are gonna die
i didn't know people were [ __ ] wing
walking i didn't know that still [ __ ]
existed and like three of them died
see what i tell you bad things happen in
three no you start over at three
keep counting them i bet thousands of
wing walkers have died
bad things happen when you walk out on a
wing you superstitious [ __ ]
um hey bill am i getting married too
young
well i've never gotten married so i
don't know i don't know what to tell you
but i will read this i'm 25
and live with my girlfriend she's great
pretty and things are going very well
i've dated her for four years and she's
by far the longest relationship i've
ever had
she's from a somewhat traditional family
where people get hitched
in their early 20s dude where the [ __ ]
do you live that you're 25
and you use the word hitched you from
buke
me and my girl getting hitched gonna
have the wedding out there in the barn
you know i figured figured we
she could get dressed up there in the
loft i'd stay down here next to the
horses
you know we ain't going to have no mu uh
music don't want to spook anybody and
any animals here in the barn right
and then i'd consummate the the
relationship over there and that stack
of [ __ ]
just [ __ ] knock her out right over
there
um god just go over there cornhusker
sorry
let's stick with the [ __ ] letter here
i've been dating for her for four years
uh but people usually get hitched where
the hell am i
um and because we've dated for a while
and i live together i already feel
pressure from her and her family to pop
the question oh jesus
yeah yeah you know you're [ __ ] you've
been with her for four years
in the middle of nowhere where they say
hitched surprised they're not coming
down there to
have some sort of exorcism anyways he
says i'm conflicted as i totally agree
with you on the whole drafting and the
first round idea
oh that's my whole theory you don't wait
to get married too long or else you're
gonna [ __ ]
you know all the good all the good draft
picks are gone
um or what you do is you you dr you pick
up someone who's proven
like a but has had a problem like a
randy moss
type of chick you know well you know
it's going to be good for a couple of
seasons before she [ __ ] tries to run
over the mailman
with the car or something i don't know
he goes i've had a great time with her
family and she does with mine dude do
you love this girl
he goes although marriage is a scary
concept to a young guy
it's not much more than what i'm the
situation i'm currently living in with
her
i probably have a peyton manning on my
hands and i can see my single friends
holding out for a shannon shop
or a tom brady in the sixth and seventh
rounds and it seems too risky
i see them chasing mediocre girls around
while i'm going scuba diving and biking
with my girl
however i'm still a young guy i haven't
dated that many girls and it seems like
it would be
fun to have random sex with some pretty
ladies in my city
my girl is awesome but i have a penis
thus the conflict
that's one of the truest things you'll
ever hear he goes all right i look
forward to hearing your advice so you
kill it up in boston
and you have more hair in your head than
you think you do ah isn't that nice
it's falling out by the day by the
second um
all right let's go back here what does
he say here uh you know what sir you say
a bunch of nice things about her but i
never hear you say that you're crazy
about her or that you love her
you know i think that that was the
biggest thing i think maybe that's
why you'd have more of a wandering eye
rather than the fact that you just have
a dick
um if you love this girl i would get
married sooner rather than later
you know every guy that i know that ever
got married and married the right one
always said it's the smartest thing i
ever did
all right you don't want to grow up like
me all right you don't want to still be
out there
drinking [ __ ] whiskey you know
looking like the owner of the bar rather
than a patron
um yeah like look you're asking me
one of the most important decisions
in your life who do i marry
should i marry this person um i would
ask myself these questions uh does
are you in love with this girl this is
is this the one is this the mother of
your kids
if if the answer is yes then by all
means
get on with it if the answer's no then
man up
break up with her buy a [ __ ] year
supply worth of condoms and uh
go have some fun that's my advice how
was that sir
um fluoride conspiracy
william i just listened to you and
derosa on uninformed
oh our old talk show comes up again talk
about fluoride in the drinking water
i've reached cer i've researched this
for some time along with other
conspiracies and it's true
fact is there are independent
researchers from all around the globe
that have done study after study on
sodium fluoride
and they all found the same thing sodium
fluoride damages soft tissue
including brain cells well you know what
i've learned with all this [ __ ]
after years of being a conspiracy
theorist is you have to you have to then
research the researchers
and it just becomes way too much [ __ ]
work and i just after a while just put
my head down and
and go as just give me a bacon egg and
cheese and just get off my [ __ ] day
here
um that's like somebody tweeted me said
uh
some scientists sometimes some
scientists say
that redheads are going to be extinct by
2060.
i love that some scientists say
what scientists what else do they say my
buddy just had a redheaded
lady now i had a reddited baby um
what last year in 2012 so in 2016 that
baby god willing will be 48 years old so
like i've said unless you people who
keep sending me this [ __ ] about
the the complete extinction
um the final solution for [ __ ]
redheads
by you know within 40 [ __ ] years
essentially
uh you might want to look into your
research a little more you might want to
research the researchers unless you have
some sort of
plan that i don't [ __ ] know about all
right
oh jesus i just pictured myself hiding
with a bunch of other redheads
with some [ __ ] brunette sympathizer
you know sitting in the wall like some
old anne frank
um anyways what are we talking about
here sodium fluoride all right as well
as bone
it doesn't really matter if you switch
toothpaste and buy bottled water because
sodium fluoride can be absorbed
topically
one study stated that dental uh
fluorosis which is slowly
sodium fluoride was proposed by the u s
government to reduce
reduce what i'm guessing cavities you
left that out uh
is in fact up to a lot higher in florida
water supply areas what happened there
what happened with this whole point
one study stated that dental fluorosis
is in fact up
to a lot higher in fluoridated water
supply
areas
that's a fragment sir isn't it or is it
the way i'm reading it what am i what
word people am i not emphasizing
that's making this sentence make sense
in my head as i hear it
um keep in mind that they get the sodium
fluoride
from smoke stacks scrub it in acid then
sell it to the municipal water
supply companies they haven't produced
one study to suggest
it does anything remotely close to what
they claim it does
not even a study to combat the other
studies
that are done almost every year by
various independent researchers from
around the world
um yeah i mean i don't know
i don't [ __ ] i don't even know what
sodium fluoride is
i don't [ __ ] know what it is do i
want the scum from inside of a [ __ ]
smokestack on my teeth i probably don't
i'd be willing to say that that does
more harm than good
you know what sir why don't you take
that [ __ ] email
and send it to a smart podcast to a
podcast that's [ __ ] smart
why don't you do that is there a science
one
a couple of guys in lab coats
sweating in their lab coats podcasting
i don't [ __ ] know here we go
william burr how do i come to terms with
being average
well let me tell you sir you're asking
the right guy
um love everything you do coming to see
your show on
august 23rd at the mgm that's right i'm
going to be at the mgm in foxwoods
connecticut on august 23rd oh and by the
way
i have a super secret very special show
that i'm going to be doing at the end of
august
all right i'm teasing it right now
with another comedian
that is way beyond me or my abilities
and i've always wanted to work with them
and i reached out to him and we're gonna
do a co-headlining show
where you ask i'm not saying [ __ ] until
tickets go on sale
when you asked i told you towards the
end of august
why bill why are you doing this you ask
because i'm learning from other radio
guys you kind of put half the
information out there you get everybody
at the
edge of their seats and then the [ __ ]
blackhawks score two goals on you and
it's over
i'm sorry how do i come to turns that i
just won't be financially successful to
the point where money is not an issue
jesus christ dude that that just made me
feel sad
why would you why would you think that
all right i guess he's going to go into
detail as to why he goes i'm 30
held many technical positions in the
corporate ladder at a few big companies
it is everything office space made it
out to be which has driven me
to file patents or ideas and
improvements as well as start a few side
businesses that didn't seem to really
take flight
well there you go sir you know
you're you're you're basing your
self-worth
on other people employing you all right
god knows i got enough [ __ ] on my
podcast e-voice legalzoom stance.com all
of that [ __ ]
for you to run a [ __ ] side business
while you're holding down your job at
this corporate nightmare that you don't
want to be in
believe in your talents dude you think i
just walked on stage and
tried three [ __ ] jokes and then it
worked
i bombed for [ __ ] years for years
and years and years like almost
the first 11 years of my career i swear
to god every time i went on stage
it was a crap shoot whether it was going
to go well or not
it was even longer than that it's
basically once you start selling tickets
and people come out to your show
that the bombing goes way down and it
also makes you softer as a comic
because people are coming out to see you
they give you a giant ovation as you go
out there they're
they're already on your side it's a home
game all right
before you sell tickets as a comedian
every night is a [ __ ] away game and
it's a rivalry game
and they [ __ ] hate you all right
so i think you're a really talented guy
i think you know what a lot of smart
people are
slightly depressed which is what how
this is reading
and dude you just gotta get yourself
force yourself to pick yourself
up off the mat and throw yourself
against the wall
all right that's not yourself sorry
stupid idea don't throw yourself against
the wall
whatever idea you got just keep putting
it out there
all right and you patent all those
[ __ ] things
and you get yourself a goddamn lawyer so
when these corporate [ __ ] come sniffing
around
and they want to dangle some carrot in
front of you you make sure you get as
much as that carrot as humanly [ __ ]
possible
all right is it donkey really that dumb
that it just keeps walking towards that
carrot
is it looking at like it's a mountain
like wow it's just way off in the
distance
you know is the donkey sitting there
praying to it's god is it just keeping
ah
thank you what what the [ __ ] would that
god be
can't say jesus i'll piss them off you
know somebody told me the other day why
don't you make fun of muslims
you [ __ ] right
i make fun of my own [ __ ] religion
all right i stay within my wheelhouse i
make fun of what the [ __ ] i know
you heard me try to talk about eastern
europe i don't know [ __ ] about it it
embarrasses me
i know anything about muslims other than
they throw down the yoga mat
every day around four o'clock when all
the stoners start getting baked
they're actually talking to their higher
power
which is my hour higher power and it's
your higher we're all praying of the
same [ __ ]
vibe that same spirit you know
so [ __ ] ridiculous and everybody's
got to do it their own way no you got to
[ __ ] tap your elbow twice
before you did it and you didn't do that
so now i'm going to saw your [ __ ]
head off
yeah and people people still show up and
give it money
and put on a silly hat right who's
getting who anytime i think i'm gonna
die i always start praying and i pray to
the god that i was told
you know i say a prayer
i say pray every time a plane takes off
and right before it lands every [ __ ]
time
say a prayer that it doesn't [ __ ]
crash you know and when i think about it
crashing i know exactly what i would say
to a higher power
i'm sorry
all right and then it'll be like when i
die and i go and get judged and he's
like
sorry for what and it just it's you know
what
yahweh lord buddha whatever the hell you
are just straight
uh straight across the board sorry
so far no not yet all of it the whole
[ __ ] kitten caboodle other than eight
percent of it
the other 92 i'm just sorry
i knew it was wrong i knew what i was
doing i tried to pull myself out of the
muck and i just
i was too weak a person you know which
maybe that's on you because you didn't
[ __ ] you know you put a four-cylinder
in me
you know instead of giving me enough
[ __ ] horsepower mentally
to pull myself out of the ditch yeah i
ain't blaming you in some way
you know you made me you know what the
[ __ ] if i made a car and it didn't run
i'm gonna blame the car oh
do what you gotta do whatever sorry
anyways back to this here um he goes i
work
50 to 60 hours a week feeling burnt
while trying my last side business
uh with no time but work i'm about to
realize
[ __ ] it dude don't don't quit
do not quit he goes uh he's about ready
to say [ __ ] it just won't be
me i won't be the guy with a lake house
or a guy who can buy cars with a
briefcase of money
or a guy with 22 year olds on his arm at
40.
all right now you're scaring me dude i
thought you were just some guy that you
know
wanted to you know wanted to invent
something and uh feel good about himself
but you sound like
dude you oh you want to move up in your
company tell them tell them that that
and your corporate
[ __ ] uh company there just tell them
that that's what you want
just walk in and just say listen this is
what i want a house by a lake
i want to buy vintage cars with a
briefcase full of money that nobody
knows where it came from
and i want some 22 year [ __ ] 22 year
old ass
on my arm the whole my whole [ __ ]
life i just want to keep trading them in
you know like that guy lived across the
street who got the new corvette every
year
because he worked for chevy right
you tell them that [ __ ] they're gonna
love it because they're gonna be like
this guy
is a [ __ ] sociopath he doesn't want
to find
love he doesn't want to make the world a
better place he wants to go out there
and get his
that's great he wants a house by a lake
we'll give him a house by a lake and
we'll give him the chemicals to dump
into it that's okay you want that house
by a lake
you got to take our [ __ ] waste and
dump it in that goddamn lake
all right now yeah i want you to
practice shrugging your shoulders
well no i don't know what got down i
want we want to see that you're going to
be able to do that
all right and if you get caught you got
to take the fall
walk up to that podium over there let me
let me see you just improvise taking the
fall
we're going to throw out a couple of
scenarios all right
just relax we got a glass of water up
there have a drink
rick okay all right first scenario um
[ __ ] sheryl crow somehow gets behind
some [ __ ] that figures out that we have
three year olds
uh making the pampers down there in
honduras
all right we need you to take the fall
go
uh yeah um okay uh
it's come to our attention that uh some
of our uh
practices in the uh undergarment
infant undergarment industry have uh
come into question
um we are looking into it
i accept full responsibility uh the buck
stops with me
and i am the head of that division and
uh
i don't like babies i'm sorry i don't
know where to go [ __ ] it [ __ ] you in
your lake that isn't good that was bad
and we can see you sweat from over here
go back to your cubicle
that's like parole that's like a parole
hearing in a corporate office
you know they bring in once every seven
years and they see how good you are at
lying
and if you're not [ __ ] good at it
they send you back to the whole
back to your cubicle it's like reverse
shawshank
um anyways let's plow ahead here
so this guy's depressing the [ __ ] out of
me he's given up on his dream and he
wants young
[ __ ] on his [ __ ] arm i don't know
what to do with this guy he goes i'm
starting to think i need to accept the
corporate grind for the next 35 years
or the whole life is going to pass me by
spending all my free time trying to
start something your thoughts
it wouldn't be right unless i and end it
this way thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
all right i don't think you're that bad
a guy sir i'm just [ __ ] with you
um all right
don't quit all right don't quit
if you quit on yourself nobody's going
to believe in you it's going to affect
your entire [ __ ] life you can't
[ __ ] quit ever you never quit
unless you're wrong you know if you're
[ __ ] wrong but then what you do is
you just go in another direction
that's all right
like let's say you always want to be a
singer but you sing like me at some
point you got to have that honest moment
be like
a [ __ ] stick at this but who's to say
that you're not a good producer you
couldn't record singers
you know or you couldn't manage singers
or you couldn't go down to the church
choir and just lip sync and act like you
were singing
right or get a sex change right and turn
yourself into some hot piece of ass and
get to the top of the pop chart
there's always a way sir and i'm not
saying to get a sex change i'm not
saying not to get one
all right just listen to me here
just [ __ ] keep don't [ __ ] give up
on that [ __ ]
that's you know what it is that's your
passion your passion is what you're
doing
when you're not working 50 to 60 hours a
week all right
and the reason why this is coming off so
depressing is because your heart is in
that
and this voice is getting louder every
day saying you don't have what it takes
and you need to quit i've been there as
a [ __ ] comic it's the [ __ ] worse
it hits you hits you right in the chest
all right you got to push through that
all right what i do is i come up with
new jokes and i go even harder the next
show
so that's what you got to do you got to
come up with a new flowbe a new george
foreman grill
a new [ __ ] ipad whatever the hell
you're working on you got to go even
harder
right and someday you'll have a podcast
and you'll repeat [ __ ] nine times in a
row and you'll mispronounce stuff
right and you'll have a house by a lake
i don't have a house by a lake but i had
one come through my [ __ ] roof three
months ago
sorry all right sir don't quit that will
crush me
knowing that you quit there's your
halftime speech do not ever [ __ ] give
up on yourself
all right what i would do if i was in
your [ __ ] situation
i would quit the corporate job first i
would
i would downsize my life
all right you got to make the sacrifices
downsize your [ __ ] life
take a job that pays less with less
hours
live with less do you need all those
[ __ ] t-shirts
do you need all that [ __ ]
do you need a laptop do you need an ipad
too do you need a mini ipad
do you need every new [ __ ] cell phone
you don't
you don't how many [ __ ] glasses can
you drink out of
at once one maybe two if you're joining
a frat
right you drink out of one
the reality is sir oh you need one bowl
one plate
one fork one knife one spoon you know
you could have all your [ __ ] yeah you
need a [ __ ] you need a bed
you need a t you need a tv you guys you
got to stay in touch right because you
got to see what's out there what they're
selling for 1995 but
other than that what do you need
nothing you don't need [ __ ]
so downsize your [ __ ] life have a
[ __ ] yard sale sir
and with that money you know
go buy whatever the [ __ ] it is you need
to buy to invent some shits you can get
out of there all right but by all means
do not accept this
as your fate it isn't you just you're
doing your open mics like i did
and you know what a lot of people
[ __ ] quit i don't know what they're
doing
okay but are they doing stand up in a
parking lot in an air-conditioned tent
in rhode island next month like i am no
they are not
all right you know what i'm saying man i
hope that that [ __ ] pumped you up
don't [ __ ] quit
or uh that don't make me sad you want to
make me sad
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't even know you
and you're making me sad
stop it all right smoking problems hey
bill what's up
nothing much what's up with you dude uh
my husband yes i'm a lady
oh i love when a woman writes in finally
maybe if i wasn't such a dick moore
would write in my husband yes i'm a lady
introduced me to your podcast last year
and we both think you're awesome well
that's great
uh we've been together for nearly 17
years and have two young children
together
i'm hoping that you can do something
using your unique sense of humor and
perspective
that i um all right that i have been
unable to do
after years of nagging and that is to
try and convince him to quit smoking
uh you know something i don't consider
that nagging
you're trying to save his [ __ ] life
all right
she says i know you you like to look
after your health and he really respects
what you have to say i want him to be
healthy
not just for his own sake but so he's
around for a long time for myself and
the kids
when we retire in 30 years or so i want
us to have health
and money to travel the world and enjoy
ourselves after a lifetime of working
cigarettes are incredibly expensive in
australia around twenty dollars a pack
and are only set to get more expensive
this habits cost
thousands every year thanks for your
help bill please never stop doing what
you're doing oh that's nice
you're welcome um oh and she says
australia next come to newcastle just
north of sydney go [ __ ] yourself
um well listen if i'm jumping on a
14-hour flight you can't come one down
one [ __ ] city south from me listen
next year i'm doing perth to sydney
all right i guarantee it or else i'll go
on youtube
and i all apologize like paula dean um
i'm sorry that i never came
out to australia
uh all right you guys sound like you're
pretty young still
and that's just the thing you think
you're gonna [ __ ] live forever and
i'll tell you what i have learned now
that i'm in my 40s
unfortunately is once you hit 40
it's no joke all right when you hit 40
whatever you've
whatever you've been doing since
you started being a knucklehead in your
teenage years
starts to take not even take root it
starts to blossom
it comes to fruition if you will all
right
if you've kept yourself in shape and
you've eaten healthy
you know you go back to your high school
reunion and people tell you how great
you look
all right if you've been eating like a
[ __ ] maniac
and smoking and all that type of [ __ ] in
your 40s
unfortunately i've learned the hard way
is when people start to die
you know there's nothing funny about
this [ __ ]
look at look at uh uh
james gandolfini you know
that [ __ ] guy was doing
what i've done but he was just doing it
too much he's doing what we all doing
over and indulging everybody does that
i mean i shouldn't say this like i
[ __ ] know but like
you know i've lost way too many [ __ ]
friends
way too many friends in the business and
outside the business i'm telling you
when you know and this isn't to tell
your husband to wait till he's 40.
uh basically from what i've read is your
body is designed
to go 150 years that's how great your
body is
and that's how [ __ ] up the environment
is and the amount of [ __ ] that you're
going to encounter
that it has to start counting down to
just so you can make it to 70 or 80.
all right and there's already enough
[ __ ] enough wear and tear
enough crap forget about all the
man-made
radiation [ __ ] uh radio waves and all
this [ __ ] and what the [ __ ] we're
putting in our food there's already
enough [ __ ] out there that can get you
and you're just you're basically you're
in the fast lane and you're gonna die
you're basically you're gonna die or
you're gonna have [ __ ] emphysema
this is what got me to never [ __ ]
smoke when i was in fifth grade this guy
came to the school and he said if you
want to know what it's like to have
emphysema
he goes make a fist so you make a fist
and
you oh [ __ ] what did i just do there huh
i turned down the [ __ ] volume sorry
about that
i just stepped on my mixer um he
basically said he said make a fist
all right this is hilarious this is what
you tell your husband
just say and this to say
hey honey do me a favor make its fist
like you're gonna mime like you're
sucking a dick
that's what you do you know what's funny
is the amount of people who are in
cubicles right now looking over their
shoulder because they want to see the
emphysema thing
bring it right up to your mouth now that
i did the dick thing every guy stopped
but they'll do it when they're home
alone tonight you know they'll turn up
the tv and bring down the curtains and
they'll try it
basically you try to breathe into your
fist
try to draw in through your mouth
through your fist that's
according to this guy what it was like
to have emphysema and that's what
that's what you're headed towards i
don't know if you guys have a daughter i
mean what if what if you're not around
to make sure she doesn't marry some
douchebag
what if the guy is a dick but you're so
frail at that [ __ ] point
because you can't do a pull-up anymore
and you got that little [ __ ] wheelie
walker thing
and you're coming in with the oxygen
tank and the [ __ ] up your [ __ ] nose
you know i'm telling you all of that
[ __ ]
people start getting those uh gin
blossoms on their nose right around 40.
all of it all of it [ __ ] comes
comes to a head at 40 but if you take
care of yourself
if you keep yourself in shape in your
20s and your 30s and that type of thing
it it it pays off [ __ ] tenfold
and uh considering you have kids man you
you owe it to them
you owe it to them all right jesus
wasn't this just sort of a feel-good
podcast you think i'd be more of a [ __ ]
after my team
lost all right i got one more read here
and then i'm gonna close out the podcast
uh stamps.com everybody
i've told you about this i've been
trying to teach you guys how you don't
have to go to the post office anymore
all right you only have so many seconds
on this earth why would you want to
spend any more time
standing in line than you have to all
right stamps.com everybody there's
nothing instant about getting postage
from the post office
driving there parking there it's really
a waste of time
when something like stamps.com is around
because you can instantly get postage
for any letter or package right from
your own desk
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use
even a [ __ ] like me can use it
buy and print official us postage using
your own computer or
printer stamps.com will send you a
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage you need
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your personal
needs
no guesswork plus it's convenient take
care of your mailing and shipping where
wherever
excuse me whenever you need to 24 7
right from your own desk
you'll never need to go to the post
office again i use stamps.com to send
out all my dvds to all my gigs
right now we got a special offer you use
my last name for a no risk trial plus
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
all right you're getting this for free
and they're giving you 55 bucks
and you get a little scale a little
meter uh don't wait go to stamps.com
right now before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr
burr that's stamps.com and enter bur
and uh you'll never have to go to the
post office again all right
unless you're one of those weirdos that
collects stamps
right i feel like if you collect stamps
you also have like a butterfly
collection
you got him pinned to that thing that
little [ __ ]
needlepoint thing how creepy are human
beings i just wanted to continue looking
at them but they fly away so i'd pinned
them to the [ __ ] boards
um all right is there anything else i
need to talk about oh
next month everybody tickets are on sale
they are going fast
and you people have told me for the
longest time please come out to the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere well guess
what god damn it
i'm coming out to the middle of nowhere
how am i doing that
on the billy redface tour red state tour
sorry
and my website is down again what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do i have to do to get
this [ __ ] website not to [ __ ] go
down every goddamn
[ __ ] three days
all right i got a phone call to make
everybody that's the podcast for this
week i was gonna tell you where i was
gonna be
you know i don't [ __ ] know the
weekend of july 12th i'm gonna be at the
cape cod melody tent
that's where i saw george carlin i saw
him before i was ever a comedian
and here it is 25 years later i'm going
back to perform there so if you think
that i'm not going to give you a [ __ ]
show that night well let me tell you
something
you're about ready to see a show that i
it should be under a [ __ ] big top
i'm gonna bring elephants to that
[ __ ] show um no
it's gonna be a very special night and
if you'd like to come down and share it
with me
i would love to have you there um next
i'm gonna be
up uh that same weekend i'm gonna be at
the
uh nantucket yachting center the
air-conditioned tent in the parking lot
just trying to be on honest and then
i'm gonna be up in uh at the hampton
beach ballroom casino
that's where i'm gonna be that weekend
of july 12th i'm playing two tents in an
attic everybody
see what happens sir working in the
corporate world when you follow your
dreams
um you get to play in tents and attics
and uh then later on that month i have
the billy red state tour that starts in
boise idaho goes to bozeman montana
deadwood south dakota colorado springs
colorado wichita
kansas i got another colorado date in
there tulsa oklahoma
ends up the whole thing wraps up in el
paso texas
i'm gonna be with uh new jersey's own
paul verzi
and uh rose bowl cook and legend
and number one cleveland fan jason
lawhead
uh we're gonna be on the bus we'll come
to your town i got this [ __ ] sick ass
t-shirt that i'm making
that has an old ford f-100 on it that
i'm only selling on the tour
um it's going to be a great time and
tickets like i said they're flying
right out of the venue so like i said i
never go to these places so if you want
to see me please go
and get tickets now all right that's the
podcast for this week
if you'd like to help out this podcast
financially um
please visit billboard.com when it's
[ __ ] up and running
and click on the podcast page and uh
you'll see the amazon banner you click
on that you go to amazon.com
anything you buy they'll kick me a
little bit of money for sending traffic
their way
and i take a portion of those proceeds
and i give it to the wounded warriors
project
also there's hard copy versions of my
latest special available
on my website uh hard copy and
downloadable if you want to get a hard
copy version bring it out to a show i'll
autograph it take a picture and all that
[ __ ]
because i appreciate you buying it and i
got a garage full of those [ __ ]
things
all right that's the podcast everybody
god bless you go [ __ ] yourself
i'll talk to you next week